[Music]
all right this morning president Trump
weighed in on the daca debate he tweeted
quote negotiations on talk have begun
Republicans want to make a deal and
Democrats say they want to make a deal
wouldn't it be great if we could finally
after so many years solve the doc of
puzzle you know this will be our last
chance there will never be an
opportunity March 5th here with reaction
former Secret Service agent and Bungie
no immigration attorney Francisco
Fernandez Francisco on this show you had
said you have said that you support
building a wall want to build a wall
build the wall okay and you said that
many times instruct the president has
said a wall with a door and we get to
people get to come in this country if
they do illegally I'm sure you probably
have no problem with ending chain
migration and no problem with the visa
lottery is it worth if the do the
Democrats really care about daca because
if they did they sit at the table
wouldn't you take that deal it's me yes
they give you deal that you can
absolutely just take it until because
the house is going to ruin it the house
is going to depart from Donald Trump as
quick as you can
Carlos Moore told me the Democrats have
to come to the table but the Republicans
were running so because they're scared
and they will abandon a voter base
my father has voted Republican since
that day he became a citizen and you
know what he says guys we are leaving
them on the table
all right I don't think the Democrats
want to deal with their buns you know
they'd rather run they don't 2018 they
don't want to do so okay so the blame
print good Dan yeah no they absolutely
don't want to deal and what Francisco is
not telling you is Barack Obama had an
operational filibuster proof majority
four months during the early days of his
campaign the Democrats could have done
it with no Republican help at all
Francisco and you know what they did I
got it simple Reba did a blood I knew it
hold on I'm not done by like they did
nothing
so please Darren listen there are a
number of Republicans by the way me
included who don't believe in amnesty i
I don't believe in breaking the law and
rewarding it but there are a number of
now who Francisco hold on who absolutely
supported daca deal I'm not one of them
miss let me pretend you have 17 years
mr. Henry you and I have gone 17 years
this is the perfect storm
we either cut a deal or we don't this is
a non-supportive the Walden the heirs
again only wants and this is a problem
damn buns you know you always get the
spending increases you never get I'm
sorry you never get the spending
decreases you always get the tax
increases you never get the wall built
you always get the amnesty you could
trace it back to 1986 96 in 2006 every
this comes up every 10 years yes if the
president does any deal he better get
the money up front because they'll never
fund the wall dan what is Mexico paying
for it
build a wall we're gonna have to
legalize a hundred thousand Mexicans to
build it and that's a darn good start
okay we may consider that it's okay man
we already saw this with Simpson Mazzoli
in the Reagan years where yeah we're
promised a bunch of stuff in exchange
for amnesty and you never get the actual
border security in the future but here's
what's fascinating you know Francisco
listen again with all due respect you're
it's amazing how you're so quick to
throw the Republicans under the bus here
when it's like this I'm looking
president on his own Twitter account who
is offering a deal it's the night yes
who are walking away all that time I
didn't are you thinking you're gonna let
me finish the sentence here are you
thinking about this rationally or
emotionally the Republican president of
the United States has offered you a deal
just take his deal Democrats will take
the deal take the deal accept the
Republican House will run from it that's
what you get them aggressive idiots in
the remotest or right for it pass it in
the Senate put the table put it on the
table let's go mr. Hanner we got a green
I've been to the border cue ball we have
we done this we have looked at it